Al
um I I'm sorry I want to ask you a deep
question but you're the voice of Moana
and I'm freaking out right now
because
like what did she teach you what did
this movie teach you and I love your
song in the movie this movie has really
rich deep interesting themes and it just
it hit me really differently it's it
it's it's like everything you love about
the original with like heaps of Scoops
and yumminess on top that's very Built
For This Day this movie is very timely I
have to agree I mean I have been also
really lucky that in my career I've
continued to play young women who go
beyond the reef or push the boundaries
or like stay straight down the barrel of
the camera I would rather be me than be
with you right and and what I took from
Janice what I hope all audiences take
away is the question of who would you be
if you didn't care what anyone else
thought of you and like if you sit with
it it it's like a profound question um
and the fact that Janice realizes this
in high school wish I could be her right
but she also has such a deep friendship
with Daman and she finds truth in Caddy
Katie whatever um and and I I hope that
everyone learns that you know you could
choose to have the followers and the
likes or you can get tight with your
click and find your chosen family and
it's worth it it really is yes and I
think it has great messages and great
lessons and the best music what the hell
oh my
God it's like the music has helped make
these themes that we've all been living
with with Mean Girls that's so iconic
like take a whole other level you're
like well of course he's going to go
with her look at her she just sang this
song and she's a Victoria Secret Angel
and oh my God I'm in you know it's like
the film just got sharper and sharper
and smarter and smarter and it tracks
better than it ever
has
[Music]
he